the u.s is bombing syria again the
united states struck two targets in
syria the pentagon is saying that this
was a decision
made not primarily by the military but
all the way to the top
by the civilian authority some people
are a little upset about this but i
think it's very important
to point out i have this on very good
information that the person who dropped
the bombs
was a biracial gender confused
millennial so this was a very very woke
and progressive bombing of syria of
course
bombing syria is about as normal as it
gets for u.s foreign policy
so in a way i think we could all say
nature
is healing we are returning to normal as
the bombs drop i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the michael knowles show
my favorite comment yesterday from
frankincensed
who says as i've gotten older i've
become less and less gay
as a matter of fact except for a few
brief years since 2009
i haven't been laughing much at all
that's true you know i remain
pretty and witty and gay myself despite
all of the
difficult news out there but it's true
words words really do change their
meaning over time i guess this is
actually the primary method by which the
left acts this is the
topic of my book coming out speechless
controlling words controlling minds
and we're sure seeing a lot of it today
one way you know amid all of this chaos
we're all really tense
that you can rest easy sleep on a my
pillow
my pillow products just do not go flat
you can wash and dry them as many times
as you want they maintain
their shape they are made in the usa
and best of all they are the most
comfortable pillow i've ever used
i would support my pillow even if it
were a terrible pillow because i like
mike lindell
i like that they support good things and
i
uh support you know fellow fellow
travelers in the conservative movement
but they're just the best pillow i've
ever used i now
i would i would buy my pillows even if
mike lindell were a liberal okay that is
how good
they are right now you get a queen size
premium my pillow regularly 69.98
for only 29.98 that's 40 bucks in
savings kings are only five dollars more
now is the time to buy folks head on
over go to mypillow.com click
on the radio listeners square there you
will find
not only this amazing offer but also
deep discounts on all my pillow products
including the giza dream bed sheets the
my pillow mattress topper and my pillow
towel sets or you can call 800-651-1148
and use promo code dailywire
nature is healing we are bombing the
middle east again
it is it's you know by one standard this
is pretty abnormal
you know but by the sort of recent
american presidency sort of trump
accepted he was a bit of an aberration
but you think biden
now bombing on his 36th day in office
obama
bush clinton bush you know
but bombing the middle east uh not not
so
out of the ordinary i want to talk not
just about
uh this sort of nature of american
foreign policy i want to talk about the
war on nature that is going on right now
on human nature
uh through this gender theory if uh
if anyone thinks that we focus too much
on gender theory
in this uh show i i just want to say i
would much rather
not waste time talking about how men or
men and women are women
the reason we have to do that as
conservatives
is because this has become issue number
one
for the left they are putting
as much of their resources as they
possibly can
behind convincing and
coercing every american into believing
that men can be women and women can be
men
and this has really ugly effects not
just on our self-understanding
but but on a very practical and
technical level this leads to the
genital mutilation of children
this is a harsh reality the left is
denying this entirely
but rand paul yesterday rand paul who i
think
had his cajones surgically transitioned
into steel
decided to bring this up with rachel
levine the
uh oh i almost said obama the biden
appointee to a senior position in hhs
who is a man who believes that he's a
woman a man who believes he's a woman is
now
in a leadership role at the department
of health and human services and he
believes
that we ought to in some cases
mutilate the genitals of children so
rand paul was not going to go down
without a fight genital mutilation has
been nearly
universally condemned genital mutilation
has been condemned by the who
the united nations children's fund the
united nations population fund
according to the who genital mutilation
is recognized internationally as a
violation of human rights
genital mutilation is considered
particularly egregious
because as the who notes it is nearly
always carried out on minors
and is a violation of the rights of
children most genital mutilation is not
typically performed by force
but as who notes that by social
convention
social norm the social pressure to
conform
to do what others do and have been doing
as well as the need to be accepted
socially and the fear being rejected by
the community
american culture is now normalizing the
idea that minors can be given hormones
to prevent their biological development
of their secondary sexual
characteristics
i am so pleased that rand paul is
bringing this up
rand paul absolutely crushing it i've
said many many very nice things about
rand paul over the
past several months because he's really
standing up on this issue
this is genital mutilation when you go
in
and you start tinkering with children's
sexuality
because of these fattish and ridiculous
theories
you are committing a particularly
egregious form of genital mutilation
some guy on twitter who first discovered
this little clip from rand paul and
popularized it on the internet he
said oh my goodness gracious he's a
daily beast reporter he says
rand paul is likening gender transition
surgery to genital mutilation
it is literally genital mutilation which
you do is you mutilate the genitals
now i'd like to anticipate the arguments
and i don't even need to anticipate them
because i did see some people commenting
on this yesterday from the left
it's it's difficult to define what
mutilation is in our society
because in order to understand what
mutilation is you have to understand
what things are
for right if i get heart surgery let's
say there's something wrong with my
ticker and i get heart surgery
they're going to go in with some
scalpels and push things around
but that's not mutilation if i
need my appendix out or something that's
not mutilation
mutilation is specifically
something that causes injury causes
damage
makes something less perfect well what
is
perfection it's when a thing is doing
what it is meant
to do so if i need heart surgery and
they go in and they
put a stent in my heart or something
that's not mutilation that's making my
heart more perfect it's making my heart
do what it is supposed to do if i go in
and turn
little johnny's uh you know manhood
into little jane's simulacrum of man of
womanhood that is almost the textbook
definition of mutilation
you are taking a perfectly functioning
organ you are then
destroying it you are preventing it from
doing what it is supposed to do
and turning it into something else but
in our culture because we basically
throw our hands up in the air and say
well we don't know what's good or bad
and we don't know
what things are for and we who am i to
judge you know what what that's for
we can't really make that argument quite
as well it is
knowable through our faculties of reason
from nature we know what the i is for
the eye
is foreseeing the eyes in their
perfection can see when the eyes can't
see
there's an imperfection that's called
blindness and we
we don't think that blindness and
sightedness
are equally perfect we recognize that
some one of those things is a
disability because the eye is meant for
for a purpose
so i actually do want to grant the
left's premise here a little bit
or i don't want to grant the premise i
want to point out that the left
genuinely can't understand what we mean
when we say that if you turn a
well-functioning organ
into some i don't know what to look like
another kind of organ
that is a mutilation and the nominee
here from joe biden
doesn't seem to understand that dr
levine you have supported both allowing
minors to be given hormone blockers
to prevent them from going through
puberty as well as surgical destruction
of a minor's genitalia
like surgical mutilation hormonal
interruption of puberty can permanently
alter and prevent
secondary sexual characteristics the
american college of pediatricians
reports that 80 to 95 percent
of pre-pubertal children with gender
dysphoria will
experience resolution by late
adolescents if
not exposed to medical intervention and
social affirmation
dr levine do you believe that minors are
capable of making such a life-changing
decision as changing one's sex
well senator thank you for your interest
in this question transgender medicine
is a very complex and nuanced field
stop it stop it right there you've
already given the wrong answer
if the question is uh do you
you really support destroying the sexual
organs of children and mutilating them
if your answer is is not no no what are
you talking about if your answer is well
you know it's complicated you've already
given the wrong answer and unfortunately
this is not just at hhs this is now
being enshrined into law
this ideology has been marching on and
on and on
gradually then suddenly you saw it
affirmed by the supreme court thank you
again neil gorsuch
it was affirmed by the supreme court in
the bostock decision which
effectively redefined legal protections
for sex you know boys and girls
as protections for sexual identity
meaning
they destroy the protections for boys
and girls right because
if if if you have a protection for
sexual identity
then you no longer have a protection for
sex if the protection for sex means that
girls get their own sports leagues but
the protection for sexual identity means
that boys get to compete in those sports
leagues
then you've just lost girls sports
leagues you just lost
the prior legal protection this comes
with the house's passage
of the equality act the equality act is
one of these
laws there are a lot of laws like this
sort of like the patriot act which
they sound so unimpeachable that if you
don't support it the patriot act you're
not a patriot
and if you don't support the equality
act you you're
you hate equality or something like that
the equality act is
the most radical legislation we have
ever passed in this country
it redefines these protections
into law now it redefines these
protections on sex
for sexual identity and
gender identity rather and sexual
orientation
this will practically if it is voted on
in the senate which hopefully it won't
be
and if it's signed into law by biden
this will
practically eradicate any
distinction between men and women
in the law will it be actually put into
effect i certainly hope not
but this is as significant a cultural up
evil
as we have ever seen this is rachel
levine defending the genital mutilation
of children at a committee hearing
or rather at a testimony on a
national legislative scale
not great stuff which means when there's
lots of risk
going on in this country you need to
check out select
quote select quote comparison shops up
highly rated companies including
prudential
banner life and mutual of omaha and
others to find you
the company with the best rates for
example select quote could find a 35
year old man a half million dollar
policy for under
19 a month that is less than a dollar a
day a cup of coffee
a day costs a whole lot more than that
select quotes breakthrough technology
allows them to quickly match you
with the best insurance company to find
your best policy
plus quotes are free head on over you
know i was thinking about this now
because i got my
cute little newborn baby you you want to
have peace of mind you want to make sure
that your family is taken care of
select quote saves you time and money
get your free quote at selectquote.com
today that is selectquote.com for your
free quote do not
put off protecting your family another
day select quote
dot com right now get full details on
the example policy at select quote.com
commercials your premium could vary
depending on your health issuing company
and other factors
not available in all states make sure
you take care of your family head on
over to
select quote
this crazy gender theory has become
somehow the defining issue of our time
when the left says that
transgender rights or the civil rights
issue of our time
a lot of conservatives we roll our eyes
they're right
in a certain sense i don't think that
there's any real comparison between
racial bigotry and the belief that
a man is a man and a woman is a woman
but it has become a defining issue
which means we live in a very stupid
time if this is the defining issue of
our time we live in a very stupid time
which means we have to get to the most
important story of the day
mr potato head for a few hours yesterday
mr potato head lost his
sex we were told by hasbro that mr
potato head would no longer be mr potato
head he would just be
potato head so much for respecting
people's preferred pronouns
when we found out that mr potato head
was being canceled
i was scurrying to the daily wire legal
department
i was running to jeremy the god king
boring's office i said we have got to
sign
a three-picture deal we need to we need
to start working with mr potato head now
we need mr potato head to come on the
sunday special
and give his side of the story but then
a few hours later
after this controversy was raging hasbro
came out and corrected the record
said hold that tot your main spud mr
potato head isn't going anywhere
while it was announced today that the
potato head brand name and logo are
dropping the mr
i am proud to confirm that mr and mrs
potato head
aren't going anywhere and will remain mr
and mrs
potato head ah we can all breathe a sigh
of relief
that the potatoes get to keep their
secondary sexual characteristics
if they are what those are i don't know
and i really don't want to know
i suspect that the
mr potato head gender controversy
was a marketing ploy i
i don't there are only two options here
either hasbro really wanted to castrate
the potato and then there was so much
pushback
that they decided they were going to let
him keep that particular
uh attachable appendage
they realized that we live in a time
that is so tense and so on edge and
there are all these controversies and
particularly around this issue of sex
and gender and they were going to
exploit that by pretending to give into
this
gender ideology but then pulling back on
it
and the reason i think this is when was
the last time
you were talking about mr potato head
i i for one can't remember the last time
i mentioned mr potato head or even
remember that mr potato head exists
and now we're thinking about it
this matters because companies realize
this is at the top of people's minds
and the way you market is you go where
people's minds are
you try to gin up controversy and then
you can sell your product
the potatoes are not the only only toy
and a product that is is doing this
oreo cookies the marketing team behind
oreo cookies getting in on it as well
oreos tweeted out yesterday quote
trans people exist
my first reaction to oreo's bold
statement here was
you are a cookie why
why am i listening to the uh
philosophical declarations
why why am i listening to the gnostic
dualist theories of a delicious sandwich
cookie
i don't know because we're living in a
very very
stupid time where everything has to be
politicized you know this
was i i hate as you know to keep
plugging my book
but providentially my book happens to be
about all this stuff that's going on
like right this very minute and this was
the plan of the people who pushed
political correctness
it was to politicize all of the terms
all of the things beginning with in karl
marx's words the ruthless criticism of
all that exists
which develops then into critical theory
which you see a lot on college campuses
now we've heard a lot about critical
race theory
into the feminists of the 1970s who said
that the personal is the political every
intimate
interaction between everybody everything
your cookies your
coffee mugs your sneakers your
relationship to your husband or wife
everything has to be open to public
scrutiny now and politicized
including oreos including mr potato head
and mrs potato head so now oreo cookie
when you eat the oreo cookie you were
making
a political statement speaking of
black and white issues how was that for
a segway
barack obama is uh is pursuing
this kind of divisive strategy not on
the sexual front but on the racial front
obama is back he's as radical as ever
he was asked about this question of
reparations
on his uh his new absolutely
insufferable podcast
with bruce springsteen we now should
i think we should outlaw podcasts i know
that i host a podcast it is my main
job i i don't i don't care springsteen
and obama it's gone too far
i i and i know we're for freedom and
whatever i don't care i'll be an
authoritarian we need to we need to
ban this this is too insufferable
to be permitted in society barack obama
on this podcast was discussing
[Music]
reparations for slavery a radical and
sort of ridiculous proposal by the
vantage of 2021
obama says that the reason we never got
reparations
the politics of white resistance
what i saw during my presidency was that
the politics of
white resistance and resentment
the talk of welfare queens and
the talk of the undeserving poor
and the backlash against affirmative
action
all that made the prospect of
actually proposing any kind of coherent
meaningful reparations program
struck me as politically
not only a non-starter
but potentially counterproductive
because of those white people with their
resistance
and their resentment we couldn't get
reparations now
first of all i love too that he lumps
affirmative action in there as though
it's somehow unnatural to resent
having a disadvantage when you're
applying to college or
or a job you know yes oh there's
it's the politics of asian resentment
that they don't accept affirmative
action at harvard and yale
that they don't accept being
disadvantaged by the admissions
committee
because of all their very white asian
privilege or asian white people i don't
know i'm very confused
but he's also just wrong on the facts
here black people do not
support affirmative action or do not
support reparations
overwhelmingly either so according to a
reuters ipsos poll from 2020 one in five
americans generally said that we should
use taxpayer money
to pay damages to descendants of
enslaved people in america one in five
people believe this eighty percent of
republicans
oppose reparations two-thirds of
democrats are not supportive of
reparations
ten percent of whites are supportive of
reparations
only half of black people are supportive
of reparations
this is a very radical view and
a proposal that is supported by a very
small number of americans
and it doesn't break down cleanly on
racial lines
if what barack obama is saying is true
then you'd say basically no white people
support reparations which is
essentially true but all the black
people support reparation that's not
true
only half of black people support
reparations and the overwhelming
majority of americans oppose it because
it's an incoherent policy he says
you know in order for us to have a
coherent policy we would need
all this white support there is no
coherent policy
slavery was abolished 150 years ago
you you already even at the time of
emancipation you would have had a little
bit of trouble with
reparations but at least you could you
know 40 acres in a mule you could have
done it
but now generation after generation
after generation many people
descended from slaves many people also
many of those same people descended from
white people the
we've mentioned on this show before the
first officially declared slave owner in
the american tradition was a black
angolan guy named anthony johnson that's
kind of weird do his descendants get
reparations do recent immigrants from
africa
get reparations it would be very
difficult how do you prove that sort of
thing
but the the real distinction here is not
a racial one it's a radical one
people who share barack obama's radical
politics and people who do not
speaking of things that black americans
are not totally sold on
it would appear that many of them don't
want to get the vaccine which we will
get to in just one second first i got to
thank our friends over at beard supply
we've made it to friday and nearly to
the end of the month which means this is
your last chance
to take advantage of the february deals
over at beard supply
i never know am i supposed to pronounce
that february or february i don't know
but anyway that is what the month is you
want your beard to grow out in style
which is exactly what beard supplies all
natural
all awesome beard oils will help you do
so go shop their febure hairy
deal today buy one get one 50
off on all of their beard oils the beard
oils are so good
that right now on my beard it doesn't
even look like i have a beard
that is how no whenever i
can finally muster up enough to overcome
the patchiness i
am very excited to try beard supply the
discount is only good for the next 48
hours though so you better act fast go
to beardsupply.com make your selection
no promo code necessary just head on
over beardsupply.com
gents since this is the last time of the
year that i can say this
happy feb you hairy now go treat
yourself to some beard oils
there is an article in the ft financial
times
the fight to overcome vaccine hesitancy
among african americans a tide of
misinformation
and centuries of medical malpractice
have led to wariness about the kovid 19
jab and the financial times goes on and
writes a very
sort of sympathetic article about this
so this issue of black people
being a little bit skeptical of the
vaccine in america this is being treated
as well
you know it's totally understandable
black people have endured
a long experience of medical experts
deceiving them and getting things wrong
and so therefore they're skeptical and
that this is true and for black people
it's true in specific ways it's also
true for all the rest of us
we've just gone through just this past
year
the experience of the most prominent
medical expert in the world
lying to us anthony fauci remember
so anthony fauci at the very least we
can say he got things wrong
and wrong and wrong and wrong and wrong
and wrong again
but i'm also pretty certain that he lied
to us
because you remember early on in the in
the pandemic what did fauci say about
that he said
there's no reason to wear a mask you do
not you don't need to wear a mask now it
won't protect you from anything
stop buying the masks don't wear them in
public
then about five seconds later he said
you have to wear the mask
we said well hold on what do you mean i
have to wear the mask you just told me i
shouldn't wear the mask
what changed and his example was i'm
paraphrasing but only slightly
he said well you understand at the time
when i said don't wear a mask they don't
do anything
i wanted to save all the masks for the
nurses i didn't think that you filthy
peasants deserved any masks
so what i did you understand is i lied
to your face
and i told you not to do it and then i
gave all the masks over to the nurses
but then when i saw we had enough
i decided that i could tell you to get
the masks so believe me
good old dr fauci that's what he said
slightly different words but that was
what he conveyed so yes i think
everybody in this country regardless of
their race has had this experience
of medical experts being wrong
and in some cases being dishonest add on
top of that that we have a vaccine
very impressive it was developed in six
months
that's pretty weird vaccines take a very
long time to build
and i'm not saying that the vaccine is
terrible or awful or it's going to cause
all these problems though obviously
people have had reactions to the second
shot
i'm not saying that i would never
consider getting the vaccine
i'm not saying that if i were 90 years
old i wouldn't seriously consider
getting the vaccine
but i am saying that skepticism is
understandable frankly it's warranted
aren't we always supposed to be
skeptical
of the scientific process i just wish
that there weren't this double standard
where
when black people have that perfectly
reasonable skepticism
they are treated as these totally
reasonable wonderful
people you know following their best
lights and when
white people or anybody else does it
we're considered monsters and serial
killers
speaking of support for things it's a
little bit of a weak transition
mitch mcconnell was just asked about
2024 mitch mcconnell you know
he didn't like trump then he kind of
worked with trump then he
threw trump under the bus especially
after the capital riot
now trump mcconnell is being asked in
2024 if
trump is the nominee would you support
him
this comes as liz cheney a kind of minor
member of house leadership says trump
should have no
say in the future of the republican
party no say in the future of the
country
mcconnell asked would you support trump
the guy doesn't hesitate
there's a lot to happen between now and
24 i've got at least four members that i
think are planning on running for
president plus some for
some governors and others there's no
incumbent
should be a wide open race and fun for
you all to cover
if the president was the party's nominee
would you support him
uh the nominee of the party absolutely
when i support the nominee of the party
ab so lutely of course this is the right
answer
romney probably would not support trump
if he were the nominee
because he he is truly never trump but
even romney said
i think it's very likely that if trump
ran he would win the nomination in a
landslide
and so this does really call into
question
people like liz cheney who claim to be
in leadership but all they seem to be
doing is dividing the republican party
this is something that we all do
particularly those of us who are
in conservative media who write articles
or books or you know have podcasts or
things like that
we always focus on the differences the
distinctions
between different types of conservatives
and i think that's very important and
it's how you
transform the direction of the party and
you try to
fix it and make sure it's going the
right way not the wrong way but if you
are
an elected republican you need to be on
the team i mean you are on the team and
you
and you really need to support the team
and i think this is true of all of us
really just to a lesser degree
conservatives are really good at
pointing out all the little minute
differences that we all have
but we we do need to come together at a
certain point otherwise we're just not
going to be able to win any elections or
do
anything and it's all going to be just a
bunch of freshman dorm room bull
sessions
when we talk about all the grand plans
we have while the left destroys the
country
the person who probably did this most
successfully in american history
was william f buckley jr when he founded
the post-war conservative movement
and now it's very fashionable to attack
bill buckley because
because i think people actually are
attacking buckley-ism
sort of what his followers decades and
decades later
claim rather than buckley himself who
was actually
quite conservative and a pretty serious
guy pretty pretty uh
strong spine in that fellow what buckley
was able to do
was unite these disparate factions
of the broader right bring them together
and actually win and actually get some
things done
was his record of accomplishment was it
perfect was it 100
we got everything we wanted no but he he
did win his fight you know i mean he did
accomplish a lot in his time now it's up
to us and i just do think
it would be helpful even as we're
parsing out our differences and figuring
out where the party should go
if we could actually bring people
together because the left
is playing for keeps you know i know
that we're supposed to say
that the 2020 election was absolutely
perfect there was nothing wrong with it
there was no reason to question it
whatsoever
i'm not someone who has said that but i
know we're that's what we're told by the
big tech
tyrants no way that we should question
anything about you know the way the vote
was conducted in pennsylvania or
how they violated the state constitution
actually that's pretty weird but no
can't question them
stephen crowder went out and
uncovered uh quite a bit of evidence
of voter fraud now i'm not i want to be
very careful with what i'm saying
i'm not saying he uncovered evidence
that the election was illegitimate i'm
not saying he uncovered evidence that
you know this was a total
but trump actually won i'm just saying
he uncovered evidence of fraud and now
people are trying to shut him up
now what i want to focus on is something
that i would swear
under oath penalty of perjury what i'm
about to present to you because
dominion isn't needed i'm not saying
that nothing nefarious happened with
dominion i just can't confirm it
i can confirm to you that these people
voted for
who may or may not be real people voted
from addresses that
do not exist so just because i don't
address some issue
relating to voter fraud doesn't mean
that i don't believe there's foul play
i do have to unfortunately hold
ourselves to the standard of
doing our due diligence and only
confirming what we've seen with their
own eyes by the way
let's contrast that with the left what
does the new york times have to say what
does msnbc
have to say no evidence of voter fraud
well really have you looked to the voter
listings have you gone to these
addresses right there's no burden of
proof on them
i highly recommend you head on over
check out check out crowder's episode on
this
it's excellent as are all of his
episodes but this one in particular
the liberal establishment is bearing
down on us
in a way that we haven't seen before
they are reverting back
all the way back to the old sort of
classical establishment foreign policy
with that slight aberration kind of
under trump
they are they're ramping things up
though they're ramping things up
on the gender ideology they're ramping
things up on the legislative front
they're wrapping things up on the
bureaucratic front
and they are ramping things up on big
tech steven crowder was kicked off of
twitter
i think only briefly but he was kicked
off of twitter for saying that
they have so much power here we need to
be
unified if we are ever ever going to try
to push back on that because this is
this is an aggression not just on some
of our political traditions
but on nature itself you know there's a
whole lot of narratives around hot topic
issues right now
it's very difficult to keep track of all
the newest controversies and
non-traverses that the left decides to
be offended by
you know you can get ready to
challenge all of this with the daily
wires newest show soon to be released
debunked
or ben exposes leftist fallacies in 15
minutes or less
climate change universal health care
coveted policies facts
and logic versus all this kind of
nonsense the show will be available
exclusively to daily wire members so if
you aren't already a member
go to dailywire.com subscribe use code
debunked
to get 25 off you do not want to miss
ben so use code debunked
for 25 off today we'll be right back
with the mailbag
all right my favorite time of the week
the mailbag first question from matt
future bureaucrat of the desantis
administration knowles well that's a
title i haven't heard before
should conservatives start getting
behind one candidate for 2024 now
such as governor desantis if
conservatives can unite as you've talked
about wow oh my god oh i gotta put a
pause there
i did not plan that i could not believe
how perfectly that first question came
out of what we were just talking about
great stuff absolutely providential
nature is but
art unknown to the chance direction
which thou canst not see
getting back to this question should we
unite as you've talked about so that we
can be successful in 2022 and 2024.
is there a benefit to waiting for
another 16 candidates to run during
election season
as the gop did in 2016 and democrats did
in 2020.
i think there is a benefit to
having a bunch of candidates run in the
primary i i am a supporter
of primaries and the reason for this is
well look we had
as many candidates run or more
candidates run than we ever have had in
the republican party in 2016 and what
happened
they all bloodied each other up and they
really bloodied up trump and then trump
won
in the general that that process of
bloodying everybody up
actually seems to have helped it's a
process the author
nicholas talib might call anti-fragility
the more you beat people up the stronger
they get
i think that's generally true of
politicians
the other reason here i mean you
mentioned ron desantis i think ron
desantis is a really a terrific
governor he's doing an excellent job and
i think he would be
a very interesting candidate in 2024
but the thing about desantis is the
thing about
all sorts of politicians that we don't
know much about
we see their strengths when they jump
onto the scene but we don't necessarily
know their weaknesses yet that's the
point of a primary process
so if ron desantis does run then we're
going to start to see that
i've compared ron desantis right now to
chris christie
and some people think that's an insult
that's not an insult i'm comparing him
not to christy in 2016 or 2020
but christy in 2012 when he was i felt a
very formidable candidate
for president he ended up not running
and we sort of found out why he didn't
run
because he had a lot of weaknesses
particularly around that time
and they came out and
i think changed our view of him i'm not
saying there's anything like that
for ron desantis i'm just saying that
you need a primary process because
if you don't if you just pick someone
who looks really really good
then you're going to get to the general
election and you might
be in store for a big surprise i also
think there are
at least at least two
or so other candidates who could be you
know
very serious very attractive contenders
for 2024.
i won't i won't necessarily get into the
horse race yet it's so early there could
be candidates that we haven't even
heard about yet but i'm i'm definitely
pro primary from alexa
michael my boyfriend and i love your
show i'm so pleased to hear that thank
you you have
excellent taste both you and your
boyfriend we're attorneys practicing in
missouri
last year the missouri supreme court
added a continuing legal education
requirement for attorneys to obtain
at least one cle credit
hour by attending a cultural competency
diversity inclusion and implicit bias
program
i've attached a picture of one of the
most woke slides i've ever seen
these people are teaching attorneys that
there should be two standards in
criminal cases
because the beyond a reasonable doubt
standard is racist we'd love to hear
your thoughts on this bs
thanks yeah this is absolutely insane
um but it is what's happening all over
the place i think the answer to this
is going to be
getting in the weeds here and what i
mean by that is not just
yelling about how dumb diversity
training is or any of these sorts of
things
we're not just talking about how
actually sort of bigoted
these issues are you know to say that
beyond a reasonable doubt is racist that
you know to say
to say the things as for instance the
smithsonian institution has in other
places
that objective reality is anti-black or
something hard work is a white
supremacist term or what
you know those terms themselves or those
ideas in and of themselves are quite
bigoted but instead of just yelling
about that
we need to get in the fight i was
talking to my friend carol swain
yesterday
who lives here in nashville and carol
terrific conservative voice and thinker
carol is proposing her own kind of
training
called unity training right we have
diversity training she's proposing
unity training i think this is a great
idea
and what it does is it doesn't just
complain and criticize
it gets in the weeds and say okay we're
going to have to have some kind of
stupid training in corporate america
we're going to do the conservative one
we're not going to do the insane radical
leftist one
and it's much harder i think for the
left to
fight that because the vast majority of
people are not paying attention to this
sort of thing
and so if if the left has
advanced by being the loudest and the
most forceful
and just getting their ideas through
because most people don't want to take
the time to deal with them
then if the right comes in and says okay
you've got to do
some kind of training we're all
accustomed to that now you've got
diversity training we can do unity
training
if the right can do that i think they're
going to be a lot of conservative
business leaders people in government
people in various associations who will
opt for that so they get the sort of
optics of doing the training and they
can check that box for most people
but they'll get the better substance i
would get in there we were talking the
other day on the
on the backstage show conservatives need
to embrace law fair
conservatives need to go in and say some
things are right and some things are
wrong we need to get much more
serious and the old throw your hands up
you know we can't
use the government at all we can't
engage in politics that idea
that we've had from like 20 2000 to
2020 gotta get rid of that from nick
hey michael big fan of the show however
i'm also a big fan of
ron paul i saw your critique of his
views on drug legalization on twitter
this evening i was wondering what your
views were on marijuana
also do you believe regulations on it
should be more stringent than that of
alcohol or tobacco thanks so much
i i don't love marijuana you know
i definitely had it a number of times
and my wayward
youth was never my my favorite i
much prefer booze and tobacco to
marijuana
so i don't i don't take a puritanical
view of it
but i think this is actually my issue
here
when it comes to to the kind of
libertarian response on drugs which is i
go with the libertarians on so many
policies i agree with them on
so many policies but then you get to
something like drugs and it reveals that
we're beginning with different
preferences
which is i think libertarians look at
the drug issue
from this very rationalist very
abstract perspective where they say
you know through all this kind of
ideological musing
i have determined that i have a natural
unalienable right to smoke pot
and if you infringe on my right to smoke
pot this is a grave injustice
and we you know we're not a just society
if we do that sort of thing
my approach to marijuana is
is it good or bad is it good or bad
now some libertarians will then say well
the moment that you take into account
a conception of the good or the bad in
society
you've gone off the rails because you
know the left is going to say this thing
is good and the right is going to say
this thing is good and it's
authoritarian and you're
coercive and you shouldn't do that all
political regimes have some conception
of the good
even you mr libertarian who are saying
we need this kind of regime
because that expands freedom the most
that is asserting a particular vision of
the good actually though
even on a deeper level liberty only
makes sense
if you have a conception of the good
because what is
liberty liberty is in just a very
practical way
it's how we intuit the good right we
have a some sense of what is good for us
and then we pursue that we have freedom
of choice to go and pursue that
we can get deeper on liberty but that's
kind of the basic thing you
liberty doesn't make any sense if you
don't first
presuppose a conception of the good and
so i i don't favor legalizing marijuana
or making the
easier to get not because i have some
abstract
absolute ideological opposition to it or
or even on the contrary support of it i
just think yeah it's not good
it's sort of foreign in the american
tradition you know in in the west we've
had booze for a very long time and
it's served us well and it's there have
been some excesses and we've kind of
wrapped our minds around it and wrapped
our livers around it you know
christ's first miracle is turning water
into wine you know uh
booze plays an important role all the
way throughout our history
marijuana is kind of a more recently
introduced thing so i'm just a little
wary of it i'm a little skeptical of it
and i don't see any reason
that we should introduce it i mean it
might be good for the
for big doritos you know might be good
for the munchie industry but i don't
really see what it does for society and
so
i just have a much less rigidly
ideological take on this and i think
generally speaking
i love libertarians i think they're
right on so many things but i think if
libertarians were a little bit less
ideological and a little bit more
practical and a little bit more in tune
with the tradition and just given into
prudence which is a very
important virtue i think that the
the two camps here would come together
much more quickly
and we'd have a much more sane politics
you know the difference edmund burke
writes about this the difference between
the english and the french is that and
and the
the difference between the american
revolution and the french revolution is
the french revolution was totally
abstract and all about these random
rights floating in the sky and the
american revolution understood rights it
understood these
kind of philosophical questions but it
was much more grounded
in a practical tradition and i think we
should
stick with that from austin i love your
show
appreciate any advice you can offer when
my wife and i got married i was a
christian in name only and she was an
atheist
we agreed to raise our children as
christians around six months ago thanks
to you and matt walsh i started taking
my faith seriously
and converted to catholicism oh terrific
very glad to hear that
since then you've changed many aspects
of my life
i've asked my wife that when we have
kids to go to church
to participate in the service pray with
them not tell them that she's an atheist
and live as a christian although she
isn't one
understandably she thinks this will make
her miserable she has no interest in
converting she wants me to handle the
faith aspect of
raising our children we argue about it
frequently and it puts a strain on our
relationship am i wrong for expecting
this of her
and if i am do you have any advice or
suggestions a tricky situation but we've
all been there
well maybe not all of us but but i
certainly have
been there in the sense that my wife and
i have known each other since we were 10
years old
we have at times believed very different
things and actually
we used to believe very different things
and even what we would believe now and
what happens
i've noticed is you either grow together
or you grow apart
you are the head of your household and
you should be the head of your household
and especially if you're taking your
faith seriously because there's a whole
whole lot about this in the bible
your duty is to love your wife
and to to lead your household and so i i
totally sympathize with her if she you
know this is not what she signed up for
she did not sign up
for this catholic family and so
she might be a little freaked out by it
she might be a little freaked out by all
the smells and bells at mass
and i think that's understandable and
you should respect that but
the thing about the faith that i suspect
has helped you come to it
and come to it more seriously is that it
is
reasonable we can know the existence of
god
from through our faculties of reason
from nature
this is in the catechism that you can
read your thomas aquinas so
i think it should be very clear if she
has an open mind and faculties of reason
that she should come to recognize that
god exists once you realize god exists
then you have to ask questions about god
you have to deal with the
reality of christ and you have to
determine what you think about the
incarnation
and claims of the resurrection and what
that means and i just i
i was an atheist for 10 years so i'm i
totally
understand your wife's hold-ups
but then i committed myself to studying
the question
and i came to this answer you know and i
think reasonable people will come to
that answer
and in the meantime you've you've got to
love your wife so i wouldn't you know i
don't think you should be bickering
about this all the time but
direct her to the mystic institute for
instance on youtube
direct her to patrick madrid's show on
the radio and you can get it on podcast
it's a great call in catholic show
direct her to
the catechism director to
catholicans.com i think it's a catholic
answer is a great resource
direct her to various resources that can
maybe help her understand this
and keep the faith and lead your
household and i think it will
uh it will serve you very well all right
last question i'm gonna fit one in right
at the end from jerome
providential too great saint who
translated the bible i appreciate the
work you do i have one question is it
possible for committed conservatives who
aren't independently wealthy to run for
and win state or national elected office
without selling themselves to interest
groups
for instance i don't see how i could win
office without millions of bucks in the
bank to insulate myself
and my family from the economic harm
that the left dishes out
no it is not for very local offices it
is for bigger offices it's not so it's
much easier
you you're much more likely to be able
to keep your integrity
if you've got at least a little money in
the bank if you don't that's fine you
need to have wealthy friends
who are not going to pressure you to
completely change your point of view
it's very very tricky
um and so you should you should work on
making sure
if you are interested in running for
office that you are insulated from some
of those threats because they come after
a whole lot of people that's our show
i'm michael nolis the michael knowles
show
see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me
andrew clavin